So you've come to a place and you need to introduce yourself.
What are some tips?
Well, let's talk about them more.
I am Hazely Lopez from Hazely Academy of Refinement and Modeling...
...and I'm here to talk to you about how to introduce yourself.
When you enter a room, the most important thing is to be confident and secure about yourself.
Always make eye contact.
That says a lot about you.
Also, when you introduce your name,...
...you have to say your first and last name.
Ask for the other party's names and follow that by repeating it.
"It's nice to meet you, Mary."
It's really important to always look for conversations.
You may wanna tell them how you have some things in common to them...
...or how do you know the host of the party.
These are some ideas that you may think about.
If you have a nickname,...
...you may also tell them that when you're actually introducing yourself to them.
Another thing to do is to always...
...try to look for things about your background...
...that you may wanna show that person.
That can open to other conversations and...
...to really have a good time and be confident and happy with yourself...
...and with the other person.
I am Hazely Lopez from Hazely Academy of Refinement and Modeling...
...and it's a pleasure to meet you.